good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can pursue
your dreams rule number five is my
personal favorite I make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips as always if someone
says something that really motivates you
really inspires you please leave it in
the comments below put quotes around
that so other people can be inspired as
well enjoy all of you have some music
playing and all of you have a heroic
mission there's no accidents in this
universe we all show up here with a
purpose there's an intelligence that is
a part of everything and everyone and
all of us are connected to it and too
many of us are afraid to listen to that
music and March to it you out there I
know you have a book you wanted to write
I know there's a composition you wanted
to compose I know there's a song you
want to sing someplace maybe you want to
raise horses out in Montana or maybe you
want to open up an ice cream shop on
Cape Cod who knows what it may be maybe
you just want to travel and see the
world maybe you want to go into a
relationship with someone but you've
been afraid to but your heart says it's
the right thing to do
all of us feel something and in leo
tolstoy his famous novel the death of
Ivan Illich
he asks this question that would be
terrifying to me he says as he has his
accountant from Moscow lying on his
death bed contemplating the horror of
this question what if my whole life has
been wrong I've known what my music is
it's playing right now
as I stand here in front of you with
these cameras and in this place and as I
sit down and write my books and tell the
world what I know are my truths I feel
always completely on purpose and
fulfilled and no time will I ever come
to the end of my life and say what if my
whole life has been wrong whoever you
are whatever that music is however
distant it may sound however strange
however weird others may interpret it to
be don't get to the end of your life and
know that you're going to leave and not
have it played yet don't die with your
music still in you never lose hope that
that you have a single breath within
your body right now and that you are
alive in this moment is hope that you
can see all these people walking on the
streets smiling is is hope that all
these entrepreneurs are posting their
art online every single day now there is
hope there that there's a single person
out in this world whose soul is still
burning alive with love is hope you know
it's so easy during these days when
sometimes there's darkness when you see
all this negative media coverage or
maybe you have a series of bad days or
series of bad weeks or you're your lucky
break just isn't coming or even fighting
for that dream you just don't sense any
of that progress that you just so need
to feel still enliven and engage and
enthusiastic about something or somebody
breaks up with you or you lose your job
or something happens with your health
look that's part of life is there's
gonna be so many struggles and
disappointments challenges setbacks dark
days and part of sustaining and making
through all of that is maintaining hope
and that hope isn't something that just
you know some airy-fairy concept it is a
psychological need
to believe that we can endure a
psychological need to believe that we
can not only endure but we can succeed
and we can thrive and we can have our
way in the world so that we can
accomplish our dream so that we can make
influence we can make our own difference
to have hope we have to stay persistent
persistent you know to keep at it no
matter what you know if we've got our
perspective in mind we've got our plan
we've got to be persistent to keep
working towards it you know there were
so many times that I almost stopped
doing these videos there are so many
times that I thought well I'm not gonna
write another book there's so many times
I thought no one cares about my blogpost
no one cares about my Facebook posts no
one cares about my YouTube show no one
cares about me oh woe is me
look we can all sit on the couch eat a
bunch of potato chips watch stupid
television to feel sorry for ourselves
that does not contribute to our liveness
it does not contribute to our connection
with those we love and care for and it
does not contribute to the things that
we create and ultimately give to the
world so we've got to say you know what
this is not what what are we going to
persist at sitting and eating potato
chips and watching TV that's not going
to be good what we have to do is persist
towards our dreams what are the three
things you could accomplish yes this day
this very day and tomorrow and start
moving towards your dreams every day
wake up with an intention I'm gonna do
at least three things to move myself
forward to something that matters at
least three things everybody can do that
just pick what are the three things I'm
gonna do to move my life forward this
day who would I need to reach out to to
be able to move forward
what can I read or study online to move
forward what could I do
just one simple request one simple
movement one simple step to move forward
and persist at that over and over and
over again and that's how things change
anything that you're going through right
now if you want to take a big scary leap
and you want to start a new career or
perhaps start a business anything that
you might consider a failure is really
just a necessary step on your journey to
success so no matter what you're facing
right now no matter what's getting you
so scared there's only one question that
you need to ask
answer to find the courage to make that
big leap and the question is this what's
the worst thing that can happen so not
just by saying yes but what's the worst
thing that could happen if you said no
so for example a few years ago I asked
my really dear friend Laura to come
speak at one of our live events now this
was a big opportunity for her but I know
it was kind of stressful and I said you
know what this is big so take a few days
think about it because once you say yes
you're going to be locked in so first
she had to ask herself well what's the
worst thing that could happen if I said
yes so for her it was the stress it was
wishing that she never committed which
she wished she never committed but it
was also this fear that she was going to
completely freeze up on stage that she
was going to mess up horribly and
completely ruin her reputation which she
did not now on the flip side she had to
ask herself what's the worst thing that
could happen if she said no so you got
to get that Laura really wanted to grow
her business and her brand and if she
said no to this opportunity she'd have
to face herself in the mirror every
single day and say nice going bonehead
you had the perfect opportunity to grow
your business and you turned it down so
now it's your turn I want you to ask
yourself what's the worst possible thing
that could happen if you said yes and
you'd fail miserably so don't just think
about this loosely I want you to get
really specific and tease out every
single scenario that could possibly go
wrong and how you deal with it if it did
what most of us discover is that no
matter what the worst-case scenario is
we can actually handle it but don't
forget you got to go on the flip side
too and ask yourself what's the worst
thing that could happen if you decide to
do nothing and keep your life exactly as
it is are your regrets going to start to
pile up like pancakes are you going to
turn into some miserable self-loathing
sad sack I really want you to tease this
one out and get all the scenarios on the
table and then take a look what do you
got what's the worst of the worst going
for it or not going for it allow
yourself to dream allow yourself to
imagine and
fantasize about all your career goals
and the kind of life you would really
like to live think about the amount of
money you would like to earn and have in
your bank account all self-made
millionaires begin with a dream of
something wonderful and different from
what they have today you know the song
that says you have to have a dream if
you want to make a dream come true it's
true for you and for everyone else as
well so imagine that you have no
limitations on what you can be or have
or do in life just for the moment
imagine that you have all the time and
all the money and all the education and
all the experience and all the friends
and all the contacts and all the
resources and everything else you need
to achieve anything you want in life you
have no limits if your potential were
completely unlimited what kind of a life
would you want to create for yourself
and your family practice back from the
future thinking this is a powerful
technique practice continually by
high-performing men and women this way
of thinking has an amazing effect on
your mind and then on your behavior and
here's how it works
project yourself forward 5 years imagine
that 5 years have passed and that your
life is now perfect in every respect
what does it look like what are you
doing
where are you're working how much money
are you earning how much do you have in
the bank what kind of a lifestyle are
you enjoying create a vision for
yourself for the long-term future the
more clear your vision is of health and
happiness and prosperity the faster you
move toward it and the faster it moves
toward you when you create a clear
mental picture of where you are going in
life and you set clear career goals you
become more positive and more motivated
and more determined to make it a reality
you trigger your natural creativity and
you come up with idea after idea to help
make your vision come true you see you
always tend to move in the direction of
your
career goals and dreams and images and
visions the very act of allowing
yourself to dream big dreams actually
raises your self-esteem and causes you
to like and respect yourself more
dreaming big dreams improves your
self-concept and increases your level of
self confidence it increases your
personal level of self respect and
happiness
there's something about dreams and
visions that is exciting and it
stimulates you to do better than you've
ever done before so here's a great
question for you to ask an answer over
and over again what one great thing
would I dare to dream if I knew I could
not fail what one great thing would you
dare to dream if you could not fail if
you were absolutely guaranteed of
success in any one goal in life large or
small short-term or long-term what would
it be whatever it is write it down and
begin imagining that you've achieved
this one great goal already then look
back to where you are today what would
you have done to get to where you want
to go what would you have changed in
your life if you had achieved those
goals what would you have started up or
stopped doing completely who would you
be with if your life was perfect
who would you no longer be with if your
life were perfect in every respect what
would it look like whatever it is that
you would do differently to achieve that
wonderful vision of your future life
take the first steps today right now you
can do anything you can be anything and
yes obstacles will come along but once
again we are living in a whole new world
some people are making a living of just
making videos
one of my favorite youtubers jenna
Marbles
[Music]
genius just a short video every single
week but she's creating abundance what
about Michelle Phan write makeup she
started way back in the day but now
she's created something for herself and
once again there was there's always
gonna be obstacles right this ain't
Paradise Island out here right here in
the jungle in the jungle you don't know
what to expect there's all kinds of
creatures so you got to ask yourself am
i surrounded myself with people that
actually are encouraging me to follow my
vision and my dream or am i surrounded
myself with what can you wear schools
these are the dream killers right it's
hard changing your life it was hard when
just over three years ago in the
Penobscot Building in Detroit Michigan
where I was operating my business and I
fell on some hard times and I was
sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment
and I said yes and I walked up to the
counter and he gave me an envelope and
he said would you mind reading it here
and I opened the envelope and the
envelope was from management that says
this is an office tower it's not a hotel
please do not sleep in your office and I
said excuse me sir I said I just worked
long hours in creating my business I'm
an entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor
all him and two other dreamers up there
look at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I can do it
there were times that I doubted myself I
said God why why is this happening to me
I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a Rob from anybody how did this
have to happen to me it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you for
those of you that have experienced some
hardships don't give up on your dream no
one could have convinced me by holding
on by continuing to push forward by
continuing to run toward my dream that
one day I would have my own talk show
it's a long shot ladies and gentlemen
from Liberty City an abandoned building
on the floor
never knowing my mother or father it's a
long shot being here with you today in
this dome in Atlanta it's a long shot no
college training labeled educable
mentally [ __ ] but I kept running
toward my dream
don't stop
Goldstar
[Applause]
[Music]
don't stop running toward your dream so
my quick take I'm pursuing your dreams I
think one it's important that you're
taking consistent action I think a lot
of people just have a dream but they
never actually do anything about it and
they see it as this next big step that I
have to take like I'm here I want to be
here I have to take this giant leap
forward and that only happens when I get
an investor or get my lucky break or you
know whatever big thing happens we're
really what ends up happening is a lot
of tiny little things happen too when
you look back lead to this big thing
where a lot of you are not doing the
little work the daily consistent work if
you're doing this thing that you want to
pursue once a week it's not enough you
have to do it daily
you have to figure out a way to find 30
to 60 minutes every single day to make
this thing happen if you already have a
business and you want to go in a
different direction you want to do
something much bigger
same thing 30 to 60 minutes every single
day working on that craft working on
that new thing starting to build
momentum starting to hone your skills
starting to make some contacts you have
to be committed to it and find the time
because if you don't then the rest of
your life is going to get away from you
everybody else has an agenda for your
time your family your customers the
people around you your friends the
government like everybody has an agenda
for your time and until you're
protective of your time until you say
this time is for me this is my dream
time this is where I'm going to spend my
energy making sure I'm doing the things
that helped me go forward until you
block that time off and set up those
boundaries around it then everybody's
gonna constantly beat you up for your
time they're gonna feel like you don't
have enough time and so most people let
their dreams just stay dreams because
they don't block off dedicate a time
every single day to pursue it to work on
it and to recognize that taking a small
step is important taking a small step
today and a small step the next day and
a small step the next day well over time
lead to big steps forward in your
business it doesn't just happen
overnight you're not just going to get
some lucky angel investment phone call
that comes to you out of the blue you
have to work at it and that sucks but if
it's your dream it was important enough
then you'll enjoy the process
enough to actually make sure that you're
doing that every single day stop letting
your dreams just be dreams turn them
into action consistently
so thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because wombat
philosophy asked me to so if there's a
topic you'd like me to cover in the next
edition of believe life leave it down
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know what did you think
of this video what was your favorite
part what did you learn most from what
was a single biggest lesson that you
took from watching this video leave it
down in the comments I'm going to join
in the discussion thank you again for
watching have an amazing day
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
man what happened to pops when he
started a business he failed
what happened to mom and dad they got a
divorce what happened to us we have six
different places was it fun
hell no wasn't fun what happened in high
school to you did you play baseball did
you play highschool basketball
did you get picked up for football did
you date to grow your life what was your
GPA who are you in high school who are
you afterwards what makes you think
you're gonna make it in life now you got
to stop selling the stuff to the sky man
stop it it's getting old go get that job
that you let go of pain you 12 bucks an
hour and part time get a degree stop
taking these damn risks we're not meant
to do something big with our lives
simple as that
are we done I'm done I'm good okay good
hat I want you to know this voice is
never going away this voice is always
going to be there no matter how much
money you're going to make it's always
going to be there the great thing about
it is though every morning you wake up
you have a choice on which voice to
listen to but I want you to think about
a complete different thing right now
let's just say you do nothing but you
say you buy into your fears but you say
you buy into every single thing you're
worried about but just say you don't
make any decisions to go after your
dreams faster over ten years from that
20 years from that 30 years from now 40
years from now but you say your funerals
are on the corner you have 50 people
there hundred people there maybe 200
people show up these your friends family
and people I love you should be left for
one generation remembered for two
generations and forgotten after that
it's a truly the life you want to live
is that really what you want to do I
don't know if that's the life you really
want to live you see what I've noticed
is no matter what you ever do you'll
have a lot of lonely times you can lie
to your family you can lie to your
friends you can fold the world into
realizing that why you didn't win was
because of some challenge that you have
to face but there's one person you can
never lie to that is a man in the mirror
you can never lie to the man in the
mirror never for the rest of your life
the man of the mirror is going to look
back at you and say you did not choose
to go after your dreams and you have to
be okay with that now
what I would like to encourage you to do
is to make the right choice I encourage
you to face your fears and pursue your
dreams go pursue the dreams that matter
the most to you you only got one shot at
this thing here and if it works out and
it's gonna feel so good for you and if
it doesn't at least you have the courage
to make that decision hope you make the
right choice I trust you will I guess
what it all boils down to you know at
the end of the day it's hair how bad a
morning how are you willing to work for
it and when we willing to sacrifice the
game you have to sacrifice your
integrity you have a sacrifice who you
are as a human being and principles of
values head I'm still moved by the
mentors when you're family you may have
to sacrifice to sleep successfully
people in this world lost a lot of sleep
oh yeah it's hi
I love the chase but God
but you know that's really what it's
about you know just just believe in
yourself so I say that to say to say
this
keep going any drain to keep going after
your goals pursue them relentlessly dig
deep down into your soul hold on to that
dream that society no let it go no
matter what be like a pitbull be like a
tiger just attack your dreams with
aggression and power for people like
what you're doing it have faith in
yourself have faith in your God listen
to your mentors and love you maybe it's
my own fault maybe I led you to believe
it was easy when it wasn't
maybe I made you think my highlight
started at the free-throw line and not
in the gym
maybe I made you think that every shot I
took was a game-winner
if my game was built on the flash and
not fire
maybe it's my fault that you didn't see
that failure gave me strength that my
pain was my motivation
if I led you to believe that basketball
was a guy given gift and not something I
work every single day of my life
maybe I destroyed the game
[Music]
oh maybe you just make an excuses
[Music]